Halloween 2018 has been a big hit with
audiences and critics alike however the
movie almost had a completely different
ending and opening scenes epic a movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
i'm revealing Halloweens alternate
ending and how the movie almost changed
the original film's finale make sure you
watch to the end to also find out all
the other deleted scenes you never got
to see if you're new here I do regular
deep dives into your favorite flicks so
make sure you subscribe and also leave a
comment about the movie for a chance to
win one of these cool merch packs
spoilers ahead for Halloween so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet
the end of Halloween 2018 saw Laurie and
the strode women trap Michael Myers in
the basement and burn the house down
leaving us with the question of whether
Michael survived originally though the
final confrontation went down very
differently but after it seems test
audiences reacted negatively
it was completely reshot in the
alternate ending Laurie ends up facing
off against Michael outside her house
rather than inside the house as happens
in the final film the deleted ending has
Laurie trying to shoot her tormentor but
missing and then she finds she's run out
of bullets Michael has a kitchen knife
though Laurie pulls out her hunting
knife and charges at him she slices him
in the arm in a reverse of what he did
to her in the 1978 movie but Michael
plunges his own knife into Laurie's
chest but just as he's about to kill off
Laurie with the final blow her daughter
Karen emerges from the house and shoots
Michael in the shoulder with a crossbow
Michael drops his knife which Alison
picks up and the three women stagger
away from the house meanwhile Michael is
injured from the crossbow arrow which
has penetrated all the way through his
shoulder and he stumbles off into the
nearby wood Laurie pleads with Karen and
Alison to kill him but her voice is too
weak for them to hear after the women
drive off in the truck the movie ends
with Michael wandering off into a
clearing with the creepy looking
mannequins that Laurie uses for target
practice the script for this discarded
ending then states that Michael sits
down by a tree and exhausted his
breathing deepens it
his last much of this ending was
actually filmed as you can see various
scenes in the trailers and promo footage
which never made it into the final movie
and it can certainly see why it didn't
test so well with audiences as in a
number of ways it's not as satisfying as
the ending we did get firstly by placing
the ending outside we would have missed
out on Michael pushing Laurie off the
balcony in a nice reverse of how he fell
off in the original movie secondly
Laurie's achievement of finally trapping
Michael in the safe room would never
have happened making her character arc
not as fulfilling and thirdly in the
final film burning down the house also
gives her an additional sense of
resolution enclosure and on top of that
the deleted ending makes it more obvious
that Michael is very likely still alive
whereas in the final film it's left open
in a more interesting way a few fans
have said that even the ending we did
get felt a little abrupt
however this alternate ending sounds
like it would have been much shorter
again and perhaps rather anticlimactic a
major change that the Halloween 2018
filmmakers almost made the franchise's
mythos is that they very nearly altered
the ending of the first movie most
shockingly if the new filmmakers had
gone ahead with their alternate ending
to the original 1978 movie who would
have seen dr. Loomis killed on-screen
fortunately John Carpenter advised
director David Gordon Green not to do
that as in his opinion it would have
really annoyed the film's fans Green
Haqq thought that he needed to go back
40 years in his new film to remind
people about the ending to the first
movie in case they'd not seen it in a
long time or were new to the franchise
and he planned to use his art director
as a body double for Donald Pleasence as
dr. Loomis because apparently for the
kind of shot they were planning he would
have looked exactly like the long
deceased actor as for young Laurie she
would have been recreated using a blend
of Jamie Lee Curtis and a young actress
with a similar bill to a 19-year old
Curtis they also looked into digitally
altering existing footage from the
original movie and I wonder if they were
thinking of doing something similar to
what rogue one did with both Peter
Cushing's character and with a young
Princess Leia they were even going to
cast one of the movies production
assistants as a young sheriff Hawkins
because he looked like a young will
Patton who plays the present-day Hawkins
and that would have been filmed as part
of a scene showing Michael being
captured by the police in the end John
Carpenter told them they were making
things way too complicated and that the
audience didn't need this extra scene to
get up to speed so instead there was
just a single line of exposition from
dr. sauteing to Lori when he explains
that Hawkins was the first responding
deputy to arrive when Michael was
arrested in 1978 interestingly there's a
little remnant of this discarded reshoot
idea in the final film look carefully at
the room where Lori and Michael face off
in the finale and you'll notice that
it's a replica of the bedroom from the
end of the 1978 movie the filmmakers had
that set built to use for their initial
idea to reshoot the original film's
climax but when they decided against
that they used the set anyway to keep
down the budget and the several
additional deleted scenes that ended up
cut for pacing purposes the first one
comes just after Michael has escaped
from the prison bus we cut to a shot of
Dana the British podcaster taking a
shower the bathroom door opens slowly
and a masked man pulls back the shower
curtain this scene was deliberately
designed as an homage to Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho which starred Jamie
Lee Curtis his real-life mother Janet
Leigh in the iconic scene the little
twist though is that the masked man
isn't actually Michael Myers if the
other podcaster Aaron playing a prank on
Dana Aaron then takes the mask off says
that wearing the mask or the legacy of
it inspires a certain tendency and then
kisses Dana little fun fact now Green
scrapped tribute to psycho would have
been doubly fitting as not only did
Hitchcock's style influenced John
Carpenter's original Halloween but also
dr. Samuel Loomis was named after a
character from psycho curiously Jamie
Lee curses mother and star of psycho
Janet Leigh has previously appeared in
the Halloween franchise playing a
secretary to a real-life daughter's
character in h2o
in fact that movie included a little
Easter Egg to Hitchcock's movie with a
shot of the same car driven by Lee's
character in the 1960s classic another
scene that was cut for pacing issues is
where Allison was jogging and saw a dead
dog hung upside down in a tree it's not
clear whether Michael killing the dog
was actually filmed however I suspect it
would probably have happened off screen
this moment would likely have been a
little hat
the two dogs that Michael killed in the
1978 film the first of which was never
shown on screen though he did partially
see the death of the second dog Lester
which belonged to the little girl
Laurie's friend Annie was babysitting by
the way if you'd like to find out how
Halloween's film makers created the
incredibly creepy kill shots we see in
the movie tap the card to watch the
secret truth about Halloween 2018 or
click the link in the description below
or on the card at the end of this video
another deleted scene revealed and
behind the scenes footage shows Laurie
coming to speak with her daughter Karen
at Haddonfield harmony community center
it looks like this was probably an
additional scene to illuminate a little
more about Karen's character maybe where
she works so would you have liked to
have seen any of these deleted scenes in
the movie and did you like the ending we
got in the final film let me know what
you think in the comments below and
remember to subscribe for a chance to
win one of these cool Halloween merch
packs if you'd like to learn more about
my theory on the movies finale plus what
I think the crazy twist with Doctor
Sartain really means tapleft for my
ending explained video or tap write for
10 freaky facts about the making of
Halloween 2018 and if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up and a
share thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers